une rétrospective inédite d'un peintre
né en 1924 à montrouge philippe lejeune
et formés aux ateliers d'art sacré au
moment où ils sont en train de
disparaître
il est l'un des derniers élèves de
maurice denis qui va mourir tragiquement
dans un accident
la route mais il aura quand même connu
deux ans ce qui va suffire pour lui
inculquer tout parce que c'était surtout
un théoricien maurice denis et le jeune
va mettre assez longtemps à assimiler
tout ce que lui a dit maurice denis et
tout ça va ressortir plus tard
[Musique]
une actualisation des sujets bibliques
le jeune représente les membres de sa
famille on retrouve ses propres traits
le train qui les traite son père et
notamment les traits de sa jeune épouse
les initiants suite au cubisme philippe
lejeune développe une peinture
probabiliste le tableau à son propre
pouvoir créateur ce que delacroix appelé
la musique du tableau philippe lejeune
l'a poussé à son paroxysme le sujet fini
par disparaître sous l'harmonie il s'est
surtout nourrie d'influencés une
influence indirecte et leur influence de
lorient voici se trouve qu'il a été à
calcutta en voiture dans une petite 4l
tout seul et il a été là frappé par la
spiritualité
qui régnait
en inde et sa rencontre avec le père
laborde aussi a été a été extrêmement
importante
la cité de la joie
et c'est après cela que ça d'inspiration
va être de plus en plus mystique en fait
apocalyptique
philippe lejeune est devenu maître de
son art aux alentours de 30 ans plus de
150 tableaux issus des collections
familiales sont aujourd'hui rassemblés à
l'espace richaud
[Musique]